what's up everybody welcome to another business Q&A ready to get our game on
help some entrepreneurs and hopefully win a game of League of Legends while we
do it I've got my usual co-host J-ryze in game and in-house and that Rishy cup
as well what's up Rishy what's up what's in your cup believe nation we're also
joined again by trainer six he's back so we'll see how we do so what is in the
company she what's in your cup today what do we got going on well I am
drinking currently my coconut coffee again and it's really good but the only
thing is that like you know how you have the last part of your coffee grounds and
there's not enough there's too much for like one cup of coffee but you know if
you don't use it all they'll let the part that's left over won't be enough
for another cup right so I have like I almost have like a double shot espresso
coconut because it's just so dark she's gonna bring the extra caffeinated energy
this morning to the stream yes so so that's my other thing is I have a cup of
I have a cup of energy out that'll be my metaphor I love it well I've got my
usual drinks plus a pumpkin spice latte courtesy of G rise today so I get to try
that out and see what the hype is all about
yeah what do you what are your any like immediate feedback about that what of the
drink yeah I'll have it sampled you know what let's do it the first sampling here
it is this is it I'm excited I've been smelling that I smell the pumpkin that's
pretty good it's like is it nutmeg what's in there yeah I like it a little
bit I'm feeling it feeling the good nice latte it's not an all-year thing though
right this is only fall fall winter right okay yeah all right well we are
waiting for a game and while we do that let's oh let's do a shout-out first
who's on our live stream Zaino's in the nice trainer sixes in game in the house
all right good you guys are all chatting with each other I shine in the dark rise
online shines in the dark all right I love it okay well let's hit my first
question what do we got nice first question comes from Evan oh okay nice
it's a great name yeah do you know the meaning of your name is there is there
like a meaning I don't think I know the meaning of the name Evan uh young
warrior nobly born I believe oh yeah that's amazing okay cool
at least that's my parents told me you know I haven't gone to validate it
anywhere else but I believe it that's great
well so Evan asked how do I get a patent he has an idea for this invention and
he's really excited about it definitely feels like it's gonna change the world
and yeah I just kind of want to know how to behind that so yeah I I think a
great place to start we actually need to check out episode five because episode
five I know we've talked a lot about how episode five is kind of like the
investment screen where we talk a lot about how to get an investor and all the
details around that but we also answer Evan does a pretty thorough job of
explaining the patent process I don't know how you remember all this Rishy I
already forgot all the episodes yeah I just keep an archive of everything so
basically you know some of the some of the like basic stuff that we did talk
about and again I would go back and listen for more in-depth but we talked
about obviously you know you need to have your your idea enough designed and
ready to actually like be at the stage where you can proceed with the patent
and there are patents that you get for a year well I guess all patents are then
if I'm not mistaken you you get a provisional patent for one year and
another interesting thing about patents is that there you have to get a patent
in individual countries so you don't get one patent and it's just works everywhere
so and then we also talked about getting a patent lawyer and some of the value of
doing that so Evan you have something to add to that um I don't remember what I
said in episode 5 about patents so I would you know what happened oh J-ryze
left the game oh okay he's gonna set up a new game except okay good yeah the
importance of a provisional patent is that it allows you to test things for a
year to see if you can commercialize it you have to pay every year for a patent
in every country to keep it alive so you have to pay you know legal fees
unless you partner up with the lawyer to create the patent but then to maintain
the patent you have to pay annual fees in every country so the provisional
patent system was designed so that it allows you to see if you can
commercialize it if you can make money from it
nice before you go out and commit to spending tons of money every year in
every country on maintaining it so it's definitely worth starting with the
provisional patent you can you could potentially do it yourself but you
really need to know what you're doing you really need to do your homework and
figure it out otherwise work at the professional the reason being the patent
is so important because you know it protects your intellectual property you
have this idea you have this invention you have this creation you know whatever
it is that you've made you have intellectual property around it and the
patent protects it in case somebody else wants to you know copy you it's a big
deal when you're getting potentially acquired or getting potential investment
they want to see right that you have a patent and the thing that you want to
think about why patent is so important is when when you're when you're looking
to get an acquired if someone's gonna buy you out part of the reason why
they're buying you is for that patent because they can't do it without you
right they want to accomplish a goal and the only way to do it is by using your
intellectual property understand that what they're gonna want to do is find
every possible reason why they don't need you like why would they go out and
pay you millions of dollars instead of just doing it themselves so they're
gonna try to work around the patent so if the patent has any kind of loophole
in it if the patent isn't done perfectly and there's some way around it then
they're gonna find it and they're not gonna pay you because why would they do
it why would they want to pay you lots of money when they could do it
themselves so that's why it's important to have a really good patent because if
you miss something then you know you're not gonna get your big payday at the end
when you try to sell it so yeah that plus everything we she said and
everything in episode 5 yes good luck on that idea and then thank you thank you
oh that other something in my throat this morning here what I have something
on my throat I'm clearing my throat a lot I don't know what's going on oh gosh
it's okay moving on okay all right we got a question from Herman actually I'm
sorry this is Herman Studios and his name is Scott and Scott asked he says
he loved your video he personally also wants to make videos for a living and he
has two questions that are kind of interesting its first one is how how
long does it take to make money posting interesting videos and then the second
question is how many videos will it take to get to the place where you can make a
living so interesting all right I think it's an interesting question only
because you know it shows that he he likes to think in terms of like numbers
and and it's so it's an interesting approach to think about how do you
measure success in a numeric way but obviously you know I'd love to hear I
can't I'm looking forward to hearing Evan what you have to say because I know
you actually have your numbers like I don't know how many videos like I have
to really work hard to keep up with like that aspect of my channel so I can't
tell you right now how many videos I've made but yeah like it the money-making
part happens as fast or slow as the value that you're contributing so you
know one one and again I don't know if you're just wanting to be on YouTube or
are you wanting to do videos that can also be utilized for other aspects of
your business that will obviously affect how you can make money but it's just
speaking in terms of YouTube since you love what Evan is doing you know I'm
sure some YouTube channels make money way faster than others because they know
the value that they want to provide they have a better you know they get to the
value part quicker than other people do and so they're going to make money
quicker and you know I think another thing just just around the YouTube model
you know you you would never expect to make a lot of money quick if you are
just relying on YouTube to be what pays you because the ad revenue that you get
from being a YouTube partner is just basically hey you'll be waiting a long
time so having a some you know having a strategy that is beyond just depending
on YouTube ad revenue to pay you is smart if you do want to get there
quicker that's it all right I'm curious for the people watching a livestream how
the sound is too I just did a YouTube livestream and I was getting crackly
sound notifications from from the people so let me know what how the sound is for
you guys so we are in game about to start I guess we got I'm jungle Teemo J
rises mid as who Victor and in trainer six is top Yasuo so this should be a fun
matchup what was the this what was the name again this person's name uh Scott
Scott Scott it's a legit question the answer the number is always gonna
disappoint you it's gonna take you way longer than you think it is and if you
focus on that number you're not gonna make it you know like you have to
want to make videos that's it you have to want to do it regardless of how many
it takes regardless of you know everything else going on in your life
regards if it ever turns into a business or not you have to want to make it I
mean what Rishy said is right no you have to be able to provide value people
have to love your videos people have to want to share it people have to be
moved by it and often you have to go through the quantity to get to that
quality right you have to you have to keep doing it get better get better get
better I have almost 4,000 videos that I've recorded now most of them are up on
the YouTube channel so it's easy to go in and think man you know I just need
that I need that simple recipe I need to know like hey if I make a hundred videos
or five videos or three videos or 25 videos that's it that's the mark but but
it's not in the the challenge is having a set number like that is if if that
becomes your goal like I need to go out and make ten videos then if you don't
hit it by ten videos and you quit and that's not the mindset that you want
coming in so the number will always disappoint you it's gonna take you way
longer than you think it's gonna take like what whatever your worst case
scenario is it's gonna be worse than that and so just prepare yourself for it
and do it because you want to do it and do it because you love it and do it
because you want to explore and see where it takes you so that's it but if
making videos makes you come alive and you want to do this and you want to test
it out then start and see if you like it and see if you want to keep doing more
but don't get so attached like it again ask this question a lot in various
different ways but thinking about like how long it will take me to have success
in my business right is it is it one year is it two years well I don't know
can you provide value in a year and in two years do you know what you're doing
you know can you help people out in that time and what happens if you get to a
year and you're not successful is that it that's the end you're not gonna
go out and continue on you know some people take some a decade to be
successful right I mean some people just take longer than others so there's no
there's no one path there's no certain number of videos and if you're if you're
asking the question my concern is that you're gonna give up too soon do it
because you want to do it do it because you love it and that's it good luck send
us your videos let's see what you're doing and this is interesting though
just a follow-up Evan is there a video that for you actually was in your mind
kind of a game changer video I think I know what you're gonna say but I'm
curious what do you think I'm gonna say video yeah okay your first will be video
when you were like okay this is what I'm doing and the little man came and
told you don't put that video and and then you did it anyway and it ended up
being hugely successful was that was that like kind of the quote-unquote the
video where success started or how do you think about it yeah there's a video
that we did actually with with J-ryze where we I was me watching my old videos
and I told a number of stories along the way of my progression as a youtuber and
a lot of different kind of marks of turning points I guess for my channel
that's probably worth watching I don't remember all the turning points there
but it's probably helpful to witness the journey of making it on YouTube I guess
that the believe it it was definitely a turning point in terms of popularity it
was my first video to hit a million views it was a video that helped me gain
confidence in what I was doing where I told you know I told this told this guy
who was in my life that and it was in the video industry that I'm doing it in
a way he hated the idea he thought it was too long he didn't like the video
but I just went ahead and did it and that that that was the biggest video
that I had on my channel up until recently Steve Jobs the Steve Jobs top
ten rules video past him past that video but it's still on my top I think it's
still top two but anyways yes that video did have a big impact I think also a
video that means more emotionally to me than success on the channel was my agent
kept wanting me to get more passionate and more emotional and more I was too
practical just getting down the business and not not getting fired up
enough which which is interesting because you know passion and fire is
part of what I do right now so it might might sound weird that I wasn't passion
enough but but I didn't I didn't commit fully to it I guess and there was one
video that I made that I guess what I guess yeah and I get before you say it
this is actually my favorite video okay tears in Malaysia no it was before that
but that was another good one okay so tears in Malaysia was I was there was a
video I made when I was I went to Malaysia I was helping some
entrepreneurs and there was this really moving moment that I had in one of my
seminars and then I went up and made a video about him the lesson I learned
there from my agent was to when you're in when you're feeling an emotional
state go out and film don't wait until tomorrow don't wait until you know next
week when when is it you're actually filming day because you'll forget you
know you could tell a story way better when you are emotional in the moment
then afterwards and try to put yourself back there and so the tears in Malaysia
was part of that training where I felt this I felt this you know wave of
emotion and then immediately decided I had to go back up to my hotel room and
film this because we didn't have it in we didn't have it on camera anywhere but
the start of that was when I came home from a mastermind group meeting that I
had with some local entrepreneurs and I felt like I I was so frustrated with
them I fought with these guys all night I felt like I was giving them you know
beautiful strategy for their business and they were holding themselves back
and it was just insanely frustrating for me and that was the first one that was
me trying to be that in-the-moment video so like I would normally film on a
Wednesday and this was a Thursday night so it was not gonna be until next week
when I have the chance to film the video and I got home at you know 1130 at night
or whatever you know crashing out and I said you know what I'm upset at these
guys a night of fighting and I'm gonna make a video about it right now and and
the video is not you know not anything amazing and didn't get tons of views or
anything but it marked more of a turning point in my mindset and that when I when
I am feeling something I should get on camera and talk about it and that led to
the the courage I guess to do the tears in Malaysia one because it just start
putting me in when I am feeling you know emotion about something don't just sit
there get on camera and start to film it so that that really marked it one of
the turning points for me now you know with that being said I don't know what
kind of videos he wants to do that's more about me developing myself and my
skills as a speaker you know if you're not doing those kind of videos it may
not be relevant or helpful but you'll have you'll definitely have these
moments where you feel like you've made really big growth you're learning you
know some of them are gonna be commercially accepted and give you
followers and you'll get a lot of positive feedback on some of them will
just be ones where you feel like you've grown personally from but again you know
you have to make sure that you want to do it otherwise just like anything else
if you're doing it because you think it's a way to just make money and it
looks so easy because all these other youtubers are doing it yeah it's not you
got to do it because you love it and if you love it then you just want to do it
and it doesn't matter how many it takes
nice that's it we had a follow-up question in the chat from Zano you
wanted to know the name the very first video you were talking about that you
made with Jay do you remember the name of it is there name that we can I want
to say it's like Evan Evan reviews his old videos or something like that
Evan looks over Evan reviews his old videos it's something like that I don't
remember them I don't remember the exact name but yeah old videos if you can't
find it let us know Jay Jay is pretty ninja at finding stuff so after after
the game I'm sure he'll be happy to search and let let us know yeah I don't
think I've seen that one that's cool all right count the game good four and
six yep not doing so well so far but we'll see we're not throwing yet we're
not throwing okay next question comes from Mike computer
Mike and mmm like actually this is just talking about big emotion so he has a
little bit of a rant he doesn't have a question okay Mike's on a rant what's up
Mike and it's all it's all out of love but he just wanted kind of like your
thoughts because it really he saw the espresso video with the I think it was
the instructor video but he referenced your video on Fred Smith founder of
FedEx okay and in the video the message that Fred Smith was talking about when
he was starting FedEx and how you know he relentlessly pursued this passion and
he fear he feared or he believed more in his idea then he feared loss okay so
the thing that Mike can't relate to is that he I guess not in the video but he
just found out or knows that Fred Smith was inherited you know I mean I don't
know if this is true but it says four million in the email you know four
million dollars and so he's like can't relate because Fred Smith had a lot of
money to basically you know you fear losing very differently when you are in
the situation we have a lot of money whereas he he's an entrepreneur he Fred
I mean Mike it wants to be an entrepreneur but he has family mortgage
to pay all that and so he's just feeling like it's not the same like what
do I you know I think I think you get it so yeah it's interesting like you know
we can't we don't choose like the families that were born into we can't
choose our parents are and there's I've heard really different views on this in
fact like there was one episode of Shark Tank I don't know if I'd be in the live
chat saw this or those who are listening but it was like the there were there
were these two entrepreneur basically what they call rich kids because they
their father was a founder of a very famous business and so they were on
Shark Tank asking for money and they had already been given two million dollars
from their father who was a founder of a famous company so you heard Barbara
kind of like really tear him apart and she was like listen I don't invest in
rich kids because they're not hungry and and I know she's like the greatest thing
I had the greatest privilege that I had as an entrepreneur was that I only had a
hundred thousand or I only had a thousand dollars and it just put a
hunger in her to like basically make it happen and then you heard Robert the
other shark just kind of say you know no success doesn't depend on who your who
your dad is and I don't know I think it's like a little bit of the end you
know I mean I think that you definitely when you don't when you don't have
certain privileges it creates a hunger that is absolutely can help you but also
you know I don't think that because you have money it means that I just think
at the end of the day we're all capable of being successful and it doesn't have
to do with the circumstances that were in so I understand the rant but I also
think that because Mike doesn't have rich parents and he does have a mortgage
in a family it could be the very thing that pushes him into success I love it I
don't remember that Mike I don't remember that video but Fred Smith was
still a hustler you know we don't have people on the channel who are just
inherited wealth and just take it easy and aren't pushing and grinding right I
mean that's not an inspiring message for for me and so I don't put it on my
channel I think for the most part the the people who are the wealthiest in the
world if you look at the people who are there that are not that are not from
inherited wealth like they're entrepreneurs you know they're they're
they're grinders they made it themselves if if anything usually the second
generation they run the business into the ground but what also shocks me is
that you're not willing to listen and learn from somebody who's accomplished
more just because they've had some success right just because they started
with more most people will start most of the entrepreneurs are starting with
less than what you already have right now most of them already do like they
have less than what you already have right now you look at Oprah right who
started with very little money had to wear potato sacks to school because she
didn't have anything you know all these advantages that are against her that
most people may have you already have more than most people and if you only
want to learn from people who have less than you or in your same situation it's
fine it can work because there's still a lot most of the success stories that we
profile are people who will come from absolutely nothing absolutely nothing
and they're the first you know in their family to go on and actually have any
kind of success but it's also limiting in that just because somebody comes from
a family of wealth and they go on and do something much much bigger that you
don't you don't feel like you can relate to them that's that's a big misstep on
you okay you know if you can only learn from people who look like you then
you're gonna have a hard time you want to be able to learn from any kind of
success and that's the point of the channel that's what we do now I mean
again luckily most of the people that we cover are less successful than you
probably already but it's just like people who feel like they can't learn
from you know they can't learn from an entrepreneur of color because they're
racist right or they can't learn from Kanye West because he does stupid stuff
too sometimes right like mm-hmm you could learn a lot from people you know
you don't feel like you can't learn from Donald Trump because he might be too
outrageous for you you can learn a lot from Trump you can learn a lot from
Clinton even if you hate them as an individual you don't learn from their
success right just like in our gratitude call earlier this morning Dana was
talking about how he's grateful for his mom even though their relationship is a
little rocky right now right nobody's gonna be that perfect person and so you
should be able to and you should start training yourself to be able to learn
from anybody who's had success so that's that's it that's my message
yep that's definitely one of my favorite of your messages um I think
that was all of his question yeah great next question comes from Salaam and
Salaam yep okay oh and by the way the name of this video that we were
referencing earlier is called yikes yeah we found it I think Jay got it for us or
I think he did I don't know it says yikes Evan looks over looks over his old
videos okay yikes explanation point Evan looks over his old videos that's gonna
be fun to watch I didn't I've never I've never seen that one when was that I
guess we don't I guess you don't have in front of you yeah I don't know yeah I
think we did it before the channel started really blowing up too so I don't
know maybe maybe time to do another one at some point yeah I love the the
reaction videos you can maybe you should start doing more reaction Evan reacts to
his old YouTube videos that would be super fun that's what that is I know
maybe you should do like maybe you should test that out do it again reaction
videos yeah okay so Salaam is the next question he says congratulations for
your wonderful job I'm a medical student also interested in computer technology
what is your advice for me all right fill in the love salaam for Evan's
channel and you're a medical student and you're you are currently a medical
student in computer technology the main thing that came to mind since it's such
a general question is to alter sure it's to alter sure I love it it's become
a verb now his last name is become a verb James alter sure okay alter sure
this I want you this is your thing you gotta alter sure here okay so I watched
this great interview with Robin and James about every day what if you do
write down ten ideas yeah he writes every morning he writes down ideas he
wanted to become an idea factory so yeah and I like this because it sounds like
you don't know what you want to do but you do know that you have this you know
you have an interest in the medical field as well as computer technology and
I'm sure that if you get into a discipline of starting to write down
your ideas every single day it might be a way that you can start tapping into
the business that you want to create because I bet that there's a way that
you can tie those two together that could be very valuable for people so
yeah my just kind of like easy what to do right now I'd be why don't you watch
that video with Evan and James Altucher and then try to implement some of that
in your life and I think it might come with some value for how to get started
the question again was he's got two different interests and he's just wanted
some general advice yeah it sounds like you know he has interest in these two
areas he's a medical student and he likes computer technology kind of just
doesn't know what to do next is what I'm what I'm guessing got it so yeah I'd be
looking at how can how can I how can I combine those things like what's a great
way that you can combine them that other people aren't really paying
attention to yet what were the two again it was engineering that he's medical
student and he's also into computer technology right okay so medical student
computer technology I'd be looking at one are you actually passionate about
both or are you only a medical student because you know your parents told you
to be that and they feel like that's the right path for you but you're not
actually that interested in it if you are interested in both then then there's
a huge market a huge opportunity for you to create you know better programs for
the medical community or if you're just doing it to make your parents happy then
maybe you should try to figure out how you can get your side hustle on to think
about how you can make it in the computer business really you know your
your success and I guess general advice for students you know your success is
gonna come by figuring out what is really unique to you and we buy some
stuff here really what's unique to you and that's that's gonna come through
experimentation and exploration and honestly your your highest value to the
world is gonna be not fitting into some box you have to create your own thing
that other people have not done before that's what you need to figure out what
is that and whether that's a mix of computers and medical school or
something totally different you have to go out and explore and see what what
fits but the the genius is going to be in that end the genes is going to be in
not just doing the same thing that everybody else is doing or not doing it
because you know somebody else wants you to do it and so figuring out what that
is for you and having the courage to go and explore and try things until you do
find that thing that just sets you on fire
nice yeah we got a lot of people in the chat up saying yeah great combination
medical and technology lots of gripping in the combination Jerry and from also
soul forged to 530 has an idea of like programming apps so what I mean so many
things you could do but yeah I agree Evan your wisdom there is absolutely
true I'm gonna think about my my first company was bioinformatics that's that's
biotech software now I didn't I'm not a coder but my partners that was their
passion they were medical researchers in a lab and they were also software
fanatics and it thought hey how can we apply our two passions and combine them
in the that's the company that they created and that that brought them a lot
more happiness and a lot more success than just staying in the lab doing
research experiments so you've got to find that that's that's like all of us
should be doing that you're gonna be you're gonna find success by being you
and finding out what is unique and different about you that nobody else can
replicate and it's gonna be by combining multiple interests that only you have
and you see connections and things that other people don't see where if you
don't combine your various love and passion it's just gonna be you'll be a
second you'll be a second-rate I don't want to just say entrepreneur but like
you'll live a second-rate life you won't be doing the things that you you really
could be doing because you're too busy focusing on other other things that you
can't be the the greatest in the world at so our team is hurting hard here but
that's it that's what I have
I never too late to like this isn't only for students right it's never too late
to figure out what your end is never too late I love it all right next
question comes from Oh thick and Oh thick wants to be an a-list rapper all
right yeah and he wants to make a positive difference in the world via
education so it kind of has a dual desire he doesn't he doesn't
specifically mention where he lives but his concern is that where he lives there
are no rappers basically or at least not anyone who understands what he wants to
do and so he thinks that you'd be a great person because he knows you know
you are just passionate hustler even use those words but he really wants to
hear from you specifically about like what do you think you should do he wants
to be that a-list rapper and but he's gonna he's in a place that he feels is
not great for that okay all right so I actually see this a little differently
because the person that came to mind was
York and how yeah like her greatest strength was the fact that she lived in
Iceland I'm not gonna say her greatest strength but one of the greatest things
about the earth was that she was from Iceland and Iceland it can't get any
different in terms of like the places in the world where people feel they should
go to be in the music industry you know but she didn't run after I can't go to
New York I'm gonna go to all you know all the places that you think you're
supposed to be at for whatever it is that you feel you want to do she
actually owned and embraced her Iceland roots and and it's what made her
different it's what made her special and I think it's part of what got her
success so I would start not thinking of the fact that you're from a place that
doesn't have people around you who get you I would start seeing that as your
asset and not as a liability and just in terms of the education piece I don't
know where you're from where you live but I do know that like at least in
America the there's actually a lot of opportunity for artists to influence
like at least in liberal arts universities and things there's like a
lot they embrace you know artists and you constantly want artists to come in
as educators to the student body because you know they they appreciate that sort
of thing so I think you've got a lot of really I see all of the things that you
want to do like I see you being set up really well and I don't see it as like
you are you know you're not any less capable of being successful because
stop making excuses that's it like you don't need to be from a certain city to
make it as a rapper you don't need to be of a certain demographic like how did
Eminem become you know the greatest rapper in the world this white guy that
people said you know white guys can't rap and here he is making as the best
rapper in the world how did you know if we're looking at the race you got Tiger
Woods the best rapper in the world is white and the best golfer in the world
is black you know and like traditionally you know really segregated fields it's
that is not the reason why you're not successful stop blaming your city sing
better pour more into your craft you have the thing called the Internet that
Eminem didn't have and he still managed to overcome if you can make cell rhymes
put them online is your stuff so good that when I listen to it like damn who's
that guy I want to go listen to his records right I want to go check out his
YouTube channel or see what he's up to it's not happening yet you need to get
better and you won't get better until you accept the responsibility for it
that's the thing whoo right like as long as you continue to blame your your
location and all this other stuff as long as that's your story then you won't
force yourself to get better where the reason why you are where you are is
because you are not good enough yet and you need to get better so practice put
all that energy that you're spending complaining about your city and pour
that back into your hustle and use that as motivation to drive and make better
rhymes feeling it that's what you need to do and I'm excited man I want to hear
some tunes to see what you got yeah um gosh you were saying something as I
wanted to just add to it darn it what did you say um darn it oh well I just
yep I agree on all of that oh okay no this is just this is really cool I'm
in something that that will also just add to your point it's like there's a
rising Oh shout out to day right there's a rising movement in the Native American
community for hip-hop and I just love that because like but not think in the
Native American community that you would see that right but here they are
totally like owning it and and they're doing it in their way they're like
representing the reservation culture at least from the videos that I've seen
that have been really cool so like they're owning their heritage in the
context of their rap hip-hop thing and it's cool so I just like embrace
whatever you're from and and use it to your advantage you you have to be the
first to be different and unique to I think about there's a great clip with 50
cent and if you haven't watched the 50 cent video you should because it's got a
lot of good wisdom to share but it's a great video with 50 cent where he's
talking about people sending him demos demo tapes and there are these guys
sending him demo tapes and they sound just like Lil Wayne and he's like man
yeah you sound just like Lil Wayne that's great job man it's it's like a
spot-on copy of Lil Wayne like if I heard this I would have thought it was
Lil Wayne himself but he's like I don't want another Lil Wayne we have Lil
Wayne already right so your whole thing and just being a Lil Wayne copycat you
know that's not what people want people want to see what you can bring so you
got to figure out what that is and it's so much easier to try to be someone else
instead of doing the hard work of discovering who you are but that's where
the magic is so get out there do it man how many rappers came from Toronto man
like Toronto was on the scene was Toronto the rap haven of the world and
you know and now who's the best rapper in the world right
Drake and is it was he out complaining and feeling sorry for himself that he
wasn't making it because he wasn't from America mm-hmm stop making excuses for
your love and it's what craft it's what made him innovate a completely new genre
of rap so that's the whole cool thing about it is like when you're from a
different place it put it sets you up for innovation way more sit you have a
video on I you mentioned the top 10 do you have an M&M top 10 yeah I love it
M&M top 10 is great and so M&M another great story I've told this before but he
did a crank call of LL Cool J LL Cool J was his what is one of his mentors oh
right yeah this video where LL was on a radio station and so he called in and he
said he was like John from Miami or something and said let me rap for you
and he started rapping LL songs and then he said you know you guessed a song and
I'm gonna rap it let's play a game and M&M is notorious for his crank calls
and they said dude you're pretty good like you should really consider going
out and getting a deal because you're you're really good this John from Miami
and the thing there is that the talent is obvious right like they don't know
it's M&M he comes on later and he starts doing his lose yourself rap so then
oh you like you know they realize he just got punked by M&M but the people
who are listening to him and LL was saying that he was really good and that
he should really consider going out and getting the deal right like is your
stuff so good that when people listen to it they want to do work with you they
want to check out more what you're all about right is your stuff that good are
you M&M level talent because I guarantee you M&M no matter where he was from
would still rise up and so stop blaming your city and start blaming your hustle
and your talent level and get better mm-hmm
love it cool this game is oh you're doing good you changed it up yeah we're
getting there we're getting there we're winning we haven't won yet though we
could still it's still we could still throw this so focus that in the chat
we've done they know kind of coming down on Drake right now but it's all good
it's wrong with Drake we're all subject artists objective right we all have our
favorite rappers I guess you know has a different rapper that he thinks is the
best rapper okay well look at album sales but whatever if he's the best or
not he made it and you can learn from him and he didn't let his city or his
country hold him back
that's right okay and next question is coming from oh I'm gonna say this say
this right Lida Lida Kelly Lida cut it with Kali says good day Evan good day I
came across your site via Google obviously I would also like to start my
own business but like all entrepreneurs I don't have the experience in capital
capital I have a huge fear of failing but I also can't shake the idea that it
might be that I it might be hugely successful sometimes I wonder if I'm
just too late to tackle a huge project like this I'm 36 I'm based in South
Africa and I don't know if it's possible for me to follow your guidelines can you
give me some advice on my concerns you'll help me so much cool so yeah Lida
Kali thanks for the question I think you know what kind of struck me about what
what she said is when she said I have a huge fear of failing but ultimately I
can't shake the idea that it might be hugely successful I think what about
that is really powerful is like when you can't shake an idea I think that is a
clue to being really on to something so I don't know I just heard of people who
like it's almost like they didn't want to go after their degree because of all
the fear but they couldn't help it because it was like what is that Tyler
Perry says when your dream dreams for you like there are times when you feel
like you can't do it but your dream dreams for you and it speaks to like
when there are certain things that like it's almost like purpose it's like you
can't shake it doesn't matter how old you are doesn't matter how little money
you have doesn't matter none of it but it's just like your dream dreams for you
and you have to do it so as my quick feedback just start do it you can do it
I love it well we won so we're back on a winning streak I went six kills and two
deaths and Jay was four kills and one death and how was trainer six 19 kills
and 10 deaths he was he was on fire so we won I love it to answer the question
there are people again who have who started way later than you like age is
not the factor and how long are you gonna let this fear hold you back are
you willing to let yourself go until you're lying on your deathbed still
with this thing left in you saying I wish that I had gone out and done it
just find a small way to get started without having to spend a lot of money
put your energy and hustle into it and just get started in a small step every
single day to move a little bit closer to that goal at least to know like even
if it doesn't work out failure is worse than the regret of not knowing so go out
and try mm-hmm go out and try find whatever smallest way it is to get
yourself going and let that let that fear of regret trump your fear of
short-term failure that's what I did like anytime I was really afraid to do
something I would just imagine myself you know 80 90 100 years old 200 years
old looking back on my life and would I regret this and that fear of regret was
greater than the fear of whatever I was in in the moment and that pushed me
through and it doesn't mean you don't feel the fear you know you will be
afraid it's okay just minimize it by doing a small step and then another
small step and another small step and there's tons of people have started way
later than you age is not the factor just go out and do it yes all right well
we got a win oh sorry you got something else no GG I was just gonna say Oh GG
yes yes we got our win we're gonna close with a message from Rishy of the
day okay just a cup of thanks to you Evan and to the people in the chat and
believe nation for being here today and just being a great place to learn so
much I love it well thank you guys for another fun week we're gonna take a
two-day hiatus yeah enjoy your weekend and we'll see you Monday again thank
you guys for watching continue to believe or whatever your one word is I
will see you soon